I haven't been human that. Often racially. Like the kids that i grew up with that are still there. You know.
I think that's lost low magic and even if you're really good place but just the period that we grew up just.
Through all those. There's something about it that you hear of kids and adults that you know.
Grew out of that experience is that incredible. And you know. It's very hard to break it you know.
I think it's one of incredible. You know.
Well i will let some friends who live in a community is still not even in that need like come here.
They're doing wonderful. Sime really good kids. Really cause this. I mean i've a few friends again.
The still the drug scene of course. One of the reasons.
When the change came to move to the bay chummed glad that i kind of moved from the mix there.
I mean you can't do not there is a drug scene in the main. But it was controlled.
Around us as kids it was never a problem at all but i mean few of my friends. You know show the.
Into the drug scene a bit. But i mean. But then there's the kids too.
On and they're doing wonderful things who are still there you know. So it's a mix you know. I think. Dan's. Issue said.
The kids who have made that you know. Spread out. Everywhere really. I have to say. My stoner really happy. Like.
I am and i can say to be one person. One kid. So cold he's probably not a kid anymore. Really one person here is.
I'm happy i mean now you've all got your ups and downs. But if it was just. I think it produced.
Are great because kids who are growing up to be. Optimists really i mean you know.
Bad things happen and we get in bad mood and we all think all the whole world can afford top of this. But.
In comparison to when else ways guy.
Mice the tarmac in his skull we can handle this problem in a on its own as i mean martha's been main armadas. You know.
There's always all i would have turned out the sign anyway. But i really don't think i would have. Artist.
Yeah it's like. There's always the brand you know. The hippie kids who grew up.
In that period their loss was wise to oh yeah they're living in suburbia. We can reform them.
We're asking is the opposite you know like you see. You can pick them out the kids to grow up with that last fall.
And they're the real they're the vibrancy the lady is you know that none of this
or that the dad ones are just in the corner smoking and stuff.
You know that they're really magic kids you know like a lot of kids are now. Have moved away from the men.
They're doing wonderful things in the city. Like really outgoing leadership stuff. You know. Academically. Art.
Everything you know and he was saying oh you know i grew up in a family here. You know. Parents were hippies and stuff.
You know. I probably won't make it as far as. If i going up there. I think it's the opposite. I think.
Just the way we look at laws. Is totally different like. Just a book. Our upbringing has made us.
Have told from a perspective of loss. Which i think is really good and.
It's just benefiting fully in high school in everything around me you know. It's really just incredibly ironic and.
And new users may know when people say oh you know.
Do you feel that those years were wasted all you know people think that that was you know the poor he'd be kids what
are white. I mean. It really is amusing because i have to say. It's a total opposite.
It was his there you see it was so it's hard to express i mean really they're all just totally amazing and it was like.
If anything i'm wasting my time getting unitas say i should be out there doing everything.
I mean realistically you know.
That's another story but you know i'm doing what i'm doing and i'm happy doing it so that's fine
but i have to say that. Weist. Is not even a word. I mean it's.
You could name and you couldn't even think of saying all year wasted years as a joke.
You know being sarcastic if you just couldn't really because it was just basically it was just an amazing time.
In living in that we decide on this is really cool in heaven he's a fan. But reflecting back on and i think is just.
When you really get used to blow yourself away i really think oh i can have a car we've had so much fun as a kid i
can't wait to learn so much before he you know.
They say it's really now that you're hearing other kids' stories and they're up bringing it realizing wow.
You know that that i mean comprehend for me that i was in a political ad a totally different lost all.
As thank god i did. You know those wonderful like your kids how i grew up and. Anything. How boring. You know.
You think wow just think when i was that i'd also of camping also of learning how to make a boomerang
and throw it out of our lot out of my cow and piper and things like that yeah i used to think that those kids.
They don't have. And i might not never have. And i'm just so i thankful. But i'm also thankful that you know why that.
The tom that i spent. Was really good. But now the norm. Out. I'm glad that on strike.
Where come free to use the knowledge that we've had since we're kids.
But go along in the last hour that we are away from him then. That's always a part of us you know. It's like. I think.
If i was still in nimbin now. You know i'd be totally different saying they might be doing wonderful things in yemen.
But also there's the drugs are.
You know there's things on the tomah spent nimbin was just incredible
and i'm really thankful that i grew up there was this incredible experience. You know.